let's talk about compositionality now
did you know that compositionality is a
powerful principle which
can allow us to endow computation with
great versatility flexibility and
expressiveness did you know that
um this idea of language of thought came
from compositionality what are your
thoughts about Chomsky
laughs
do you like Chomsky
I'm taking this dog home with me it's
amazing she is great absolutely amazing
um is it Patrick Esser uh Lewis Patra
I'm so sorry no worries lovely to meet
you uh lovely to me look into the mic
okay
um so you were the guy who wrote this
paper about retrieval augmented
generation yeah uh I guess so I mean
there were papers before here
um but I was part of a team
um led a team that wrote a paper that's
kind of captured the modern imagination
of like making a
simple ish end-to-end model that learns
to retrieve and then learns to generate
based on what it's retrieved
and we call that model rag but yeah
there's a sort of long history of this
that stretches back you know tens 20 30
years as with most things in like AI I
can imagine I mean I'm so excited about
this because clearly there's the Google
code red so they're racing to do
something like this I think the Bing
team are racing to do something like
this that you know there are lots of
problems with language models in terms
of like they they hallucinate
and so on absolutely but this ability to
go out and get actual you know like
epistemically true Justified true things
and stick them in the prompt and then do
the generation I mean why don't we just
like zoom out and you know give me give
me an interview yeah I guess just before
like just to pick up on on the kind of
like language you're using there I
wouldn't call it like epistemically true
but it's more
um it's like I can support my viewpoint
as a human and I can argue and you don't
necessarily believe me until I give you
a source but even then you may not
believe the source but at least you've
got something to back it up so like we
can't make language models
generate truth what we can do is make
them more verifiable so we can produce a
generation
that might be like a factual claim or a
claim about the world that the language
model is inhabiting and we can use that
mechanism of citation effectively or
grounding which is how humans have kind
of converged on how to like have kind of
scholarly or actual debates and so the
language model can generate
both this claim and a
piece of
an artifact from The Real World that it
can use to say oh here is something that
supports my viewpoint here or here is
why I'm saying this it may not be why
depending on like your views on
uh the definition of why
um but at least it's saying like here's
something that you can look at and if
you trust this source
then you may trust uh what I'm saying
here the why thing is actually really
interesting is I was talking to um
Professor Luciano floridi last week and
and he talks a lot about
um you know obviously like pragmatics
and semantics and like the the
information context so for example if
you said is this the same building or is
that the right building
um if you're just asking for directions
yeah the building's over there but um
you might be asking is it still a
hospital does it still have the same
function and then the why the purpose is
important so he said there's like
um uh you know the the question the
purpose and the answer you need three
not two
question the purpose and the answer yeah
that makes that makes a lot of sense
um so yeah going back to you know like
all the sort of frenzied uh um activity
to try and spin up these
conversational search interfaces
um
or kind of equivalently turn to actually
chat GPT into something they can cite it
sources and ground like it makes a ton
of sense
um there's been this kind of line of
work in the in the more of a obscurement
of not obscure but like in Academia for
a long time and so I kind of watched
this slightly almost bemused and mean
like well of course you know along this
comes and these models as the models get
better they're obviously going to get
better information seeking dialogue
which is like the term that we use for
this and then people have made it from
information seeking dialogue into
information seeking dialogue plus
rationales which is something that came
in a few years ago and now more with
this concept of
attribution or grounding or citation
they're all kind of different words that
describe roughly the same concept but
yeah like this is clearly a huge thing
that many
large teams are working on and some like
smaller teams as well yeah yeah and it's
something I'm like super interested in
I've worked on a lot with my ex
colleagues and my colleagues here
um throughout my PhD in and at fair and
here as well
amazing so how does rag work exactly how
does rag work so
um
they're sort of like the high level
concept which is a piece of text comes
into the model or like there's some
input even higher text like if we're not
talking about language and I was just
talking about models in general
something comes in we analyze that thing
that comes in
and
we also have a knowledge base of items
um and we try and figure out for the
thing that's come in what are the most
relevant or important things from my
knowledge base that might help me
produce a desired output yeah and we
perform a step of retrieval which can
look like
generating like an actual search query
with a language model
executing it on
Google or Bing or whoever and then
taking those search results and then
passing them into a second step
which is where you take those retrieve
results and the initial input and then
you try and figure out the best response
based on the on both of these two things
[Music]
um and
what I would describe as rag as the
process of training a model to do both
um so that
you yeah it can operate kind of like a
standard language model except in the
middle there's this retrieval going on
and and then what you get is sort of
better as we've talked about
interpretability because you can see
where the claims might be coming from
you can inspect the retrieve documents
if it generates these kind of explicit
pointers back to the documents you can
inspect those and you also get other
things like an aspect of updateability
so language models as I'm sure you've
talked about with a bunch of people one
of the key flaws is that they take you
know
a great deal of resources to train
and then they're sort of stuck in
whatever time they were trained but if
you have a language model with access to
a big external memory like the internet
or like a big index of text you can put
things in and take things out and you
can then update them
to have
new
knowledge that's come along since so you
could arguably teach Bert about covid by
giving it a Wikipedia index to read uh
read um or like retrieve from on the fly
or you can also remove things as well
which is kind of like a more subtle
thing so let's say there's some bad
stuff or something undesirable that your
model is conditioning on
uh if it's a retrieval augmented model
you can find that thing that it's
retrieving and using and remove it so um
I was involved in a piece of work
late last year called Atlas which is a
language model that has this retrieval
augmented generator kind of paradigm
and I was looking at the performance of
a model like the performance of the
model on a benchmark that people use to
see how well this Muse models do a
question answering called mnlu massively
multitask language understanding
and that's a collection of exams like
multiple choice exams like the SATs and
all things you might take in high school
or
um there's some University level ones
there's like a lot of them
and what I was doing was looking at the
performance and we saw really good
performance and then I was looking at
the retrieved
information that the model was making
use of in order to help it answer those
questions correctly what I found is that
it was retrieving a lot from stack
exchange which was part of the data that
we put in there
and what would happened is that people
had been set these exams for their
homework and they'd gone on to the
internet and they just Googled the and
they'd Googled it hadn't found it and
opened a stack exchange thread you know
on the Obscure thing they've been asked
to do and that had just been like
sitting on the internet
and then we had come along and we'd
added Stock Exchange to our information
we were effectively like cheating or
leaking our performance on this data set
by retrieving the exact question and the
exact answer that someone had Googled
like Googled and then put on stack
Exchange
and that was like not a reflection of
what we were trying to measure we were
trying to see whether this was a sort of
general purpose system that could use
external information to answer its
questions but not like literally just
find the same question somewhere
um so what we could do with Atlas which
we couldn't have done if this was just a
big normal language model is we just
took out stack exchange from the data it
was training from and then if we
measured this leakage like looking
verbatim for those questions in the
things we were retrieving we didn't have
them anymore so we can then be like okay
here's how it would do if we've
controlled for explicit memorization
yeah yeah because that was something
that I didn't I don't think I grasped
completely so rag is
um learnable
so it's like because I guess what I had
in my mind candy was like you create
this computational graph you go to these
operational stores uh with Google you
might generate a query but it might be
let's say a bunch of documents and
you've got embeddings for them and you
select ones with a cosine or whatever
um
and you kind of fan out and then you get
a whole bunch of information back and
you do something with it yeah so there's
like it's a sort of very broad Paradigm
of like a model that searches and then
consumes search results to produce an
output and then
relevant to the conversation just now is
that like the the grounding part but
that's really just part of the
generation part
um within that there's a whole universe
of kind of designs
um some people would call rag this
techless sort of area
um some people will call it a specific
model that was published whenever we did
it like three or four years ago
um that is like one instance of this
type of model so like there's a sort of
a definitional problem that people don't
quite have the right
terminology to describe this
um some people would call like this
approach a retro
um because retro is another like example
of models in this kind of family that do
something pretty similar
um
right yeah and then there's the you know
you can either train a kind of pipeline
of these models that's existed for a
really long time like trainer retrieval
system for example to try and retrieve
documents that are likely to answer a
question and then plug that into a
reader model that takes those passages
and the question and tries to extract uh
the actual answer that's been around for
a super long time like like 10s 20 30
years
um but really they're just evolution of
the same kind of idea with more and more
powerful models that get stronger
um I mean is it I know nothing about
this but is that where a lot of the
complexity comes in so when you have
diverse
um you know operational stores that you
aggregate over because I'm kind of
thinking if you just go to Google then
that must be much easier than having to
kind of like aggregate over five stalls
yeah so you can either like kind of
build your own differentiable store or
you can use Google or you could do so
like I guess there's a question about
whether it's a black box search engine
uh or a differentiable model that you
control
um and then there's a separate question
of like if it's a black box
what's inside the black box so that
could be Google or it could be
elasticsearch or some other thing that
you can't differentiate with or you can
go the fully diff
the mostly differentiable route where
you have the more
um familiar dense Vector
um retrievers that people use nothing
you were describing okay that's how rag
Works rag is one of those ones with a
purpose-built kind of explicit memory
with vectors
uh that you train the retriever
and you train the generator and you try
you basically try and join the train
them jointly with one loss function
that's trying to make them both work
together but you can
train them
kind of separately together so you can
imagine train the retriever so that it
retrieves documents that happen to
give you a better likelihood if you plug
them into a language model okay and then
train the language model to make better
use of those documents
and then a little bit later go back to
the Retriever and try and encourage it
to retrieve the documents that
maximize the probability of the language
model so you can kind of do this I'll
train the retriever for a bit based on
what the language model likes and I'll
train the language model a bit based on
what the retriever likes and you can do
this kind of shuffling process and that
means you can
you can train models that
may not be end-to-end differentiable and
kind of exist in their own
you know they can you could literally
have them training on different servers
um but you can end up with a system like
your model that works together so kind
of style of what's called an em
algorithm uh
but yeah there's there's sort of
sometimes people formalize it that way
some people just sort of say hey we're
going to distill some stuff into the
retriever now and hey we're gonna train
the language model based on this um so
it's all a bit of a wild west and it's
more of an empirically driven right now
than any like specific way of training
these things yeah that's cool I think
the one thing I'm missing is so the
retriever model I think just gets back a
bunch of documents and because I was
kind of thinking maybe you might have
been saying sometimes the retrieval
model might actually be a language model
decoder itself but but the question is
like how do you get that information
from the retrieval model and you have to
do something to it and put it in the
prompt yeah so that's a good point so
the retrieval model
could be any model I guess that takes in
the original input and then produces a
list of documents from our index so
if our index is the entire internet our
retrieval system could look like let me
put the input and we get let the
language model generate a Google search
query and we run that through Google or
it could be any kind of other like
design but um
or it could even be a language model
itself that you've kind of forced to
only generate certain types of output
there's there's work that does that as
well but yeah so the retrieval part the
kind of signature of the task is
input to list of documents
and then the second stage is the
signature of the task is input list of
documents to output and
generally that will look something like
concatenating the text of the input
either with the long list of documents
together
um or
concatenating the input with each of the
documents separately the top K documents
and then feeding them independently
through the language model and then
doing some what's called marginalization
at the top to produce a final output but
yeah like the prompt either looks like
squishing all of the text together or
squishing the text with with the input
and putting it through yeah because
because the the problem we seem to have
with the language models is that they
have a certain context window size and
you know could could be yeah eight
thousand could be four thousand could be
two thousand great point and so it's not
like we can just stick it all in there
you can't stick it all in there but
um you can
do
some things to make it less
uh so like you could stick it all in
there but it would take a really long
time and it would have a really high
memory complexity so the Transformers
have a quadratic complexity which means
like as the sequence gets longer
uh it becomes N squared amount of memory
required to process it there are some
like fancy tricks that you can do to
make that Less in practice but generally
we don't want to have a super long
sequence
um what you can do instead is this trick
that
um we're talking about is basically
imagine that
you can feed the input with each of your
documents independently
and what that looks like is a bit like a
batch of standard training so usually
you have like a prompt and you have a
and you get the language model to
generate and you can parallelize that so
you'd usually have a batch of like
16 examples that you throw through what
we could do instead is have the same
question
uh with 16 different documents yeah and
then you kind of create this batch and
you can throw that through a GPU
and that would allow you to effectively
process all 16 documents
in parallel separately and then at the
top of the language model you have to do
some kind of integration like of the
information what we call fusing so
fusing information across the documents
is like a big
deal and there's various ways you can do
it in the rag paper we did this right at
the top of the language model so we're
effectively for each document
we are predicting what the next token
should be for the output
and then we're saying Okay so
the question plus document one predicts
the next token should be
a
uh the question plus document two
predicts the next token should be sum of
a maybe sum of B and document
3 for example might say dot um B and so
what you do is then sum up the
prediction of what the next token should
be second is your fuse or an encoder
decoder Transformer um so this the
uh that's one way so yeah like that you
can use an encoder decoder as the
architecture but it's more General than
that it's sort of like it doesn't matter
if it's an encoder decoder or just a
standard left to right language model
you can still
run them in the same way some of them be
more efficient than others except for uh
the next thing we'll talk about so what
I was saying is like in rag that's kind
of how we did it we took predictions for
what the next token should be for each
document and then
um
you average effectively and then you put
it the next token then you can repeat
the whole process
um what we found since which is work uh
led by my colleague ex-colleague Gautier
is a car uh is that
getting the model to have a cross
attention
or attention over both the query
and the documents earlier
improves the model A Lot which is why
where the encoder decoder models come in
so Gautier and eduar came up with this
architecture called FID or Fusion in
decoder which does use an encoder
decoder model
and it works kind of like the way I
described uh so you concatenate the
question with each document and you
parallel process through the encoder and
then you take all of these latent
um encoded States and you concatenate
them
effectively halfway up through the model
so the decoder then attends on all of
the encoded documents
um
so that it can generate so you kind of
fuse
in the middle or fuse in the decoder so
that's what we call it Fusion in decoder
that's a way of effectively avoiding the
terrible memory complexity and time
complexity that comes from concatenating
all these documents in the super long
line yeah at the bottom which would
probably be the most optimal in terms of
performance maybe we don't actually know
that
um but or it would have the most
powerful cross-attention layers but
obviously is difficult to do in practice
so yeah
amazing amazing um unfortunately I have
to go in a minute but just a final
question you just like brought this
question on I've always wondered you
know we've got this quadratic biowise
complexity and Transformers and um
you know like we just think that if we
could have a Transformer with a huge
input size you know we could ingest an
entire book it would just be better but
that's not necessarily the case like can
you think of any limited like for
example language might have some kind of
explosive complexity like with all of
this kind of like you know relational
structure that and and that might grow
quicker than the representational
capacity of the language model so do you
think that's super interesting yeah so
certainly a model that needs to process
like an entire book in one forward pass
will require more capacity
you know well
I'm not sure about that actually but
I'll take a step back and say
um
we can't reason about it too much
because that's just so different from
how humans absorb information like they
don't sort of like stare at a book laid
out on a table and you're like Okay
[Music]
um
also you might need to like backtrack a
bit more so uh
I'm not sure a human does this but uh
but a language model is gonna have to
read the start and then it's going to
reveal things about stuff that happens
later
so yeah so a left to right language
model at least the ones that are like
really popular the the GPT style ones
um we'll read the beginning
but they won't revisit how they've
interpreted the beginning by the time
they come to the end so
it's a little bit sub-optimal from that
perspective you'd kind of want reading
to be a bit more active this is
something that Jason Weston
um argues for is that reading is a bit
more of an active process that you kind
of read a bit consume it so I just keep
going maybe summarize
um you know what you've read so far put
it into some sort of working memory or
scratch pad or whatever people want to
call it
um and then continue and that's not
something that
we train a language model to do out of
the box so even if it's context window
is really good it might not have a great
ability to process say the beginning
um without knowledge of the end
so you could have a big old
bi-directional model that can do that
but again it feels like the best thing
to do would be read a chapter for
example generate some sort of working
memory of that
and then
keep doing that effectively and so like
your kind of process becomes
given my summary and the next chapter
what's my next summary and you kind of
take the whole alter aggressive language
modeling Paradigm and move it up
to like a higher kind of level of
operating on sequences
um
I guess there's another separate issue
which is even if I could train a
language model with this like incredibly
long context window
do we have enough signal to train the
model to actually use that information
um so we don't we have lots of short
sequences like billions trillions of
short sequences and we know that the
next like the the most important tokens
are the ones near the one you're trying
to predict next which is the signal that
language models use to train
um as you go further and further away
there's this big old drop-off in how
important those tokens become and to the
point where you want to get a model that
understands super long sequences there's
just so little data comparatively for it
to pick up on those signals so you might
need a super big language model that's
got loads and loads of capacity just
even to recognize
um or like be good enough at language
and role to to be able to
fit these last few really rare signals
um or you might have to fake it somehow
and like artificially produce these very
very long documents
um so that the model can can do well
yeah amazing Patrick's spinning on it
great thank you so much yeah thank you
thank you cool cool um yeah my drive is
waiting outside and that was really
really cool man yeah thank you
I think I think it's okay I'll just like
chicken Chuck it all in the bank but
yeah that was awesome thanks a lot